les menaces place aux nouvelles
sanctions pour la première fois depuis
le début de la guerre l'union européenne
s'attaque aux exportations énergétiques
de moscou avec la mise en place d'un
embargo sur le charbon russes
représentant quatre milliards d'euros
par an les 27 ont également décidé
d'interdire certains exportations de la
russie notamment les exportations de
biens de haute technologie autre
sanction les navires russes n'auront
plus le droit d'accéder au port de
l'union européenne avec toutefois
quelques exceptions ce qui concerne le
transport de denrées alimentaires
d'autre part la liste noire des
personnalités russes dont les avoirs
dans l'union européenne sont saisis va
encore être élargi actuellement
877 personnes et soixante deux entités
ont déjà vu leurs avoirs gelés sur le
territoire de l'union
côté financier les vingt-sept interdit
également toute transaction avec quatre
grandes banques russes soit un quart du
secteur bancaire du pays